- Il y a un an presque jour pour
jour, les premières voitures
du REM, fraîchement débarquées
de l'Inde, étaient dévoilées
en grande pompe.
SERGE MAI, dir. tech., Systèmes
et matériel roulant, CDPQ Infra
- Ça a été fabriqué par des gens
qui ont une grande habitude
de faire ceci.
- Mais au fil des tests
effectués à Brossard et
surtout au fil des inspections
des wagons reçus, la Caisse
de dépôt, responsable du projet,
a vite déchanté.
Des bar Des bar Des bar Des bar
les passagers mal soudées,
des fils électriques mal
protégés, des marques laissées
après le mauvais ajustement
d'une porte...
Les problèmes de finition
sont nombreux.
Dans cette lettre adressée
au constructeur Alstom par leeee
patron de CDPQ Infra Jean-Marc
Arbaud, on peut lire que :
JEAN-VINCENT LACROIX, CDPQ Infra
- Il n'y a pas de panique
en ce moment, au contraire :
les choses avancent bien,
mais de notre côté,
on le voit par cette lettre,
on a une volonté d'être
extrêmement rigoureux dans
la qualité du produit final.
- Le conAlstom assure
que c'est lui qui va payer pour
toutes les réparations à faire
et ajoute qu'un plan d'action
détaillé a été mis en place
depuis la réception de
cette lettre pour améliorer
la situation, ce que
la Caisse de dépôt confirme.
- Il n'y aura aucun impact
tant sur le coût et l'échéancier
avec ce dont on parle
parce qu'on est vraiment
dans la finition.
- Mais cette histoire donne des
munitions à ceux qui auraient
voulu que les 212 voitures
du projet soient fabriquées
au Québec plutôt qu'à l'usine
d'Alstom de Sri City, en Inde,
où les ouvriers gagnent
2 dollars de l'heure.
François Legault jette la pierre
à l'ancien gouvernement libéral.
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
premier ministre du Québec
- Je l'avais dit quand
j'étais dans l'opposition, là,
je l'avais dit haut et fort :
Ça n'a pas de bons sens
qu'il n'y ait aucune condition
de contenu québécois dans
la commande du REM.
LOUIS BÉGIN, prés. Fédération de
l'industrie manufacturière-CSN
- J'espère qu'on va tenir compte
de ce dérapage-là pour pouvoir
donner des contrats, qu'il y ait
des retombées pour le Québec,
et en plus de tenir compte
de l'expertise des travailleurs
québécois.
- La Caisse de dépôt ne s'engage
pas à construire au Québec
la deuxième phase du projet
le REM de l'Est. Elle précise
toutefois qu'elle aura la
volonté de maximiser le contenu
local tout en respectant
les accords internationaux.
Ici Jean-Sébastien Cloutier,
Radio-Canada, Bro